[Musica]
buonasera a tutti quanti o di solito non
salgo sui palchi perché di solito la mia
vita è lì dietro
ero lì dietro
questo giovedì per la finale di xfactor
perché sono un agente e a questa cosa
ogni volta la gente che guarda con un po
di dubbi perché non capisce se sono un
agente immobiliare
se sono un agente
un agente se ho sbagliato qualche
vocale quindi non realizzano
puntualmente io vivo lì dietro perché è
giusto è quella la mia posizione e non è
giusto mai oltrepassare un limite un
limite che stasera in qualche modo oltre
basso ed è un onore e un onore perché
sono tarantino e questo teatro per me
rappresenta
tantissimo perché quando ero piccolo ero
seduto lì e venivo del weekend a vedermi
film sul film su film e mai avrei
immaginato che alla soglia dei 40 e
anche io come andrea delogu non li
dimostro sicuramente
andrea e no scherzi a parte io ero
sempre seduto lì tutti i week end per me
vedere film qui era era un sogno venivo
la mattina con la scuola quando
finalmente non si faceva lezione mamme
non me ne fregava niente perché dovevo
vedere i film e non si capiva perché
fossi così tanto motivato mia madre mio
padre erano arrabbiati perché passavo le
giornate su sorrisi e canzoni su tutti
questi giornali televisivi e guardavo
notizie prendevo punti tutta roba
inutile non serviva a nessuno e fate un
porno studiavo niente e non ho
assolutamente idea di come io poi si è
riuscito nella mia vita a concludere
qualcosa perché ho procrastinato
procrastinato inventando improvvisando
esattamente quello che io sto facendo
stasera perché non avevo assolutamente
idea di quello che avrei potuto dire
perché parliamo di viaggio quando ho
sentito pier francesco nacca che
ringrazio tantissimo e dopo di rho il
perché ero in viaggio
esattamente dieci giorni fa e arrivavo
da un altro viaggio arrivavo da un altro
viaggio ancora nell'ultimo mese ho preso
qualcosa come 10 aerei più di 10 treni
questa è la mia vita io faccio questo mi
muovo mi sposto vivo per gli altri e mi
mi dimentico sempre di chi sono io
quest'anno ha sorpreso deciso di andare
da una psicologa non l'avevo mai fatto
e sono arrivato lì l'ho guardato detto
ma chi sa che cosa dirò per un'ora lo
letteralmente rincoglionita perché ho
parlato al trans mi guardava
incredibilmente vede comunque
interessato nelle più attenzione quello
che dico è utile utile almeno per farti
monetizzare non è vero se mi stai
guardando quando uscirà questo video ti
voglio bene
è fondamentalmente è il motivo per cui
sono finito in terapia che per me è
successo niente perché il mio lavoro mi
porta purtroppo a dimenticarmi anche di
chi sono e questo è un grande ostacolo
perché la mia storia è un po una favola
e un po no io mi sono laureato in storia
e critica del cinema al lecce
facevo avanti e dietro taranto lecce
tutti i giorni quindi
strano anche vai via ma non è vero non
va via prima di questo fatto altre
facoltà lì o fallite tutte quindi quando
dai miei genitori sono tornato dicendo
io vorrei ricominciare università vanno
guardare alle cose guarda la cia sta non
fa niente possiamo inventarci ben altro
e infatti jiao anche per taranto e
distribuendo volantini quello che per me
è fondamentale lo dico io spero che
siate tutti i tarantini perché per me è
importante
io giravo per taranto con questi
volantini quello sguardo basso perché mi
vergognavo ne vergogniamo perché ero
stato un bambino prodigio perché a 5
anni facevo le divisioni perché leggevo
tutto a 34 anni quindi c'erano grandi
aspettative io a vent'anni 21 anni
quant'era giravo per la città
distribuendo quei volantini che la gente
odia che mi sono preso tante di quelle
parolacce e però guardavo le persone e
nessuno mi guardava male era tutto un
mio pensiero nonostante questo io me ne
sono andato
ne sono andato perché volevo lavorare
nel cinema ma non sapevo da dove
cominciare volevo fare lo sceneggiatore
e lo sceneggiatore per chi non sapesse
scrive i film i film sono scritti in
maniera differente dai romanzi perché se
io devo dire che già ne arrabbiato non
potrò dire che gianni arrabbiato perché
dovrei stare tutto il tempo nel film
così quindi gianni da un pugno volevo
fare questo
uno sceneggiatore molto importante che
si chiamava giorgio arlorio uno
sceneggiatore che ha scritto i film di
alberto sordi si è innamorato di me
ovviamente in maniera artistica e mi ha
spronato mi ha spinto mi ha dato tante
di quelle motivazioni e ci ho creduto e
lui mi diceva sempre guarda che chi
vuole lavorare nel cinema ti vuole
scrivere chi vuole creare chi vuole fare
qualcosa è un organizzatore di viaggi e
quindi questa cosa del viaggio torna
torna e mi fa molto sorridere perché
nonostante io viaggi continuamente e
abbia vissuto in spagna a lecce a roma
da tanti anni io sono ancora residente a
taranto e non voglio cambiare tutto
questo è più forte di 20
è il motivo non lo so non c'è un motivo
valido perché fondamentalmente la
spazzatura proveniente la faccio pagare
ai miei genitori però non è per quello
non non ce la faccio non riesco andar
via da questo posto è
ed è strano perché se ci pensiamo la
cosa che mi mimì mi fa sorridere è che
tutti noi tutti quelli che mi hanno
preceduto e che verranno dopo di me è la
maggior parte dei tarantini hanno
raccontato le loro storie se ne sono
andate se ne sono andate da questa città
che di per sé in coin in maniera
inconcepibile per essere amata la devi
abbandonare ed è una cosa molto triste
perché taranto è che io faccio due palle
così a tutti i miei amici perché taranto
e meravigliosa si parla di bello stasera
e io ogni volta che penso al bello penso
al mio mare penso la mia città che è
bistrattata che è maltrattata che che
non è famosa uno dei motivi per cui io
sono stato preso poco in considerazione
quando ho cominciato il mio percorso
lavorativo è stato il mio accento e
all'epoca mi prendevano in giro io oggi
sono la gente di cinema e mi occupo di
una serie di artisti vi dicevo ero lì
giovedì per xfactor perché sono la gente
del presentatore ero a sanremo
quest'anno perché sono la gente di
matilda de angelis che lo ha presentato
sono la gente di vari attori beppe
fiorello raoul bova sono io uno degli
artefici del prossimo don matteo
raul ti vogliamo bene
esco es
e anche questo i pro ei contro
però sto giocando sono sono un agente di
cose che mi stimano sono la gente di
elodie di diodato per le canzoni cioè io
faccio per le canzoni medicina è più
forte di me io non so bene dove ho
cominciato perché continua questa strada
però il tempo mi sta dando ragione
secondo me se io non fossi stato di
questa città se non avessi questo
pensiero questo sentimento non avrei
ottenuto nulla di tutto questo
e lo dico sinceramente perché a roma
dove vivo non mi capiscono quando io mi
perdo nei miei discorsi esattamente come
sta succedendo stasera però avrei
talmente tante cose da dire che come si
fa in dieci minuti è un po complicato ha
detto scherzi a parte
è un percorso strano la cosa che mi
rattrista ripeto è tornato torna
sull'argomento e che per per fare quello
che più ci rappresenta fare la
differenza per portare alto il nome di
taranto te ne devi andare quando ero in
viaggio appunto chiamato
pierfrancesco è che tutte le persone che
lavorano con lui e che ringrazio io ho
detto io voglio fare qualcosa sono un
agente stimato inutile che ci gira
intorno lo so l'ho capito fingere
sarebbe ipocrita e vorrei usare il mio
lavoro vorrei usare l'attenzione che
riscuota oggi che chi mi sono guadagnato
perchè nessuno mi ha regalato niente per
la mia città non ho ben capito cosa come
non ho capito in che modo ma lo farò e
ci sarà in qualche modo qualcosa che io
riporterò qui oppure riporterò taranto
da un'altra parte non lo so il cinema in
qualche modo permette di disegnare è
stato detto più volte stasera io penso
che quello che facciamo noi
nell'ambito cinematografico permette
siti sono responsabili di cose di cui
non siete sicuramente contenti vedere
delle serie brutte dei film poco
piacevoli ma allo stesso tempo sono
quello sono parte della squadra che vi
permette di tornare a casa dopo aver
visto un film al cinema ora che
finalmente hanno riaperto e magari
sognare esattamente come succedeva a me
e tornavo a casa sognavo perché perché
volevo far parte di tutto questo questa
città non melo non me lo permetteva ma
nonostante questo invece oggi gode del
del mio lavoro e non ce l'ho fatta ce la
sto facendo che è diverso semplicemente
perché in qualche modo non ho mai
dimenticato da dove sono partito il
paradosso e chiudo e che è il mio grazie
sincero a questa serata e che per me
questo forse uno dei momenti più belli
della mia vita perché partire da taranto
io ho faccio un viaggio continuo
continuo continuo per lavoro e mi scordo
dove vado e tornare qui è il mio punto
di arrivo definitivo
qui posso rifare i bagagli e
ricominciare un nuovo viaggio poi avevo
bisogno di tornare quello desiderato
ardentemente dal momento in cui ho
cominciato il mio lavoro
il cinema non lo sa gli attori non lo
sanno non è importante basta per l'uso
io e basta che lo sappiano i tarantini
quindi per me basta e avanza grazie a
tutti